in time Florida Governor Rick Scott will
meet with families and victims the
deadly school shooting today before he
decides whether to sign new gun
legislation into law new audio reveals
what happened in the moments after the
gunman opened fire inside Marjorie
Stoneman Douglas High School
my daughter just texted me from school
she's had summoned Douglas and she says
there's an active shooter the Broward
County Sheriff's Office released nearly
a dozen 911 calls Adriana Diaz is in
Tallahassee with how the audio offers a
clearer picture of what happened during
the attack
Adriana good morning good morning of the
81 calls that went to Broward County
9-1-1 operators 10 were released
yesterday including one that appeared to
be from a student inside who was afraid
of raising his voice many of the other
calls came from parents who are relying
information from their children inside
she says she's behind the desk right now
but the shots were close the calls from
parents flooded local 911 operators
during the shooting in one a panicked
mother is overheard speaking directly to
her daughter
seconds later police escorted the
students from the classroom 9-1-1 what
is your emergency in a call from inside
the school a cry for help
had to be whispered the caller too
afraid to be heard by the shooter are
you at the school are you at the school
[Music]
also released radio transmissions
between law enforcement including the
school resource officer Broward County
sheriff's deputies Scott Peterson who's
been scrutinized for staying outside the
building
Peterson's lawyer insisted he thought
the gunfire was happening outside but
just two minutes into the recording
Peterson's attention was already on the
building where the shooting was
unfolding and he radioed that the
disturbance was happening inside
Peterson who's denied any wrongdoing
never entered the building to confront
the shooter and at one point even warned
first responders to stay away Peterson
has since retired now yesterday the
Broward County Sheriff's Office said it
wants to release the surveillance video
but that decision is ultimately up to a
judge Nora can only imagine Adriana
thank you